or si at si Book Festival for Twitter so
please put those out there out into the
the ether ether the internet I should
say I would first of all like to ask
everybody to please silence your
cellphone's so if you haven't done that
please put those off and they have also
informed us that flash photography is
not permitted in the room the way that
the event is going to work today is that
I'm going to do a brief introduction of
Lydia she's going to give about a 15
minute presentation on her work do some
short readings from the book I'm then
going to ask her a few follow-up
questions and we will have some time at
the end for audience members to ask
questions of the author and then I also
want to let you know that she will be
signing books in the Barnes & Noble tent
immediately following the event so if
you would like to get a signed copy and
I believe oh yes and one of the fossils
that we're going to talk about today is
the tonk child we have a couple of casts
of him up here but at the book signing
tent if you would like a 3d print of the
fossil I do have those to hand out so
definitely stop by and pick up your copy
of the tonk child from today absolutely
so let me introduce Lydia Pines she's a
writer and historian who's interested in
the history of science in the history of
material culture she got an
undergraduate degree in anthropology in
history from the universe Arizona State
University sorry and also received a PhD
in history at ASU as well she has done
archival work and field work around the
world including the American Southwest
South Africa Ethiopia
who's becca stan and iran and she
currently lives in Austin where she has
a position as a visiting fellow at the
Institute for historical studies at the
University of Texas at Austin 7
skeletons which I highly recommend it's
a very readable book and really brings
to light the celebrity of fossils is her
third book
and her work has appeared in places like
the Atlantic Nautilus the appendix and
the public domain review so please join
me in welcoming Lydia pine well thank
you and thank you all for coming I know
that this is the last session for the
San Antonio Book Festival and so I
really appreciate you guys I'm taking
the time to come out and talk fossils
and the history of science I'm really
excited and I am excited to spend the
time here to talk about seven skeletons
the evolution of the world's most famous
human fossils my latest book here and to
also talk about the nature of celebrity
science how do how do scientific
discoveries become famous
why do you say certain scientific
discoveries become famous and others
don't these were the questions those
those sets of questions for what really
motivated me to start working on this
particular book project the idea that we
know certain things really well we know
Charles Darwin we know Isaac Newton we
know about Lucy this famous fossil but
why do we know about those instead of
other other things that did just as much
for the scientific community we're able
to put forward scientific ideas all of
those sorts of things so that's really
what sort of under underscored my
interest in writing a book like seven
skeletons which sort of brings us to the
point what is seven skeletons about well
it's about seven skeletons now so it's
about seven seven fossils that are
famous they're significant in the
history of the study of human evolution
and I was interested in picking these
particular seven some might be well
known to people like Lucy Neanderthals
we probably all heard about Neanderthals
some of the other ones might not be
quite as familiar like the Piltdown hoax
or maybe sediba which is a very recent
discovery but I picked these seven
because I felt like they were different
kinds of famous sort of seven different
kinds of famous and I thought that that
would be a really interesting way to
explore the history of science
in the history of human evolution so the
book is written as seven profiles almost
as if I take each of the fossils and
turn it into a biography so the first
chapter is a biography of the old man of
la Chapelle in the and earth all and we
work our way through the other seven and
we can certainly sort of step back and
talk about and talk about that in the
Q&A session and the research in order to
in order to get into and be able to put
together the biographies of fossils it
definitely draws from a lot of different
disciplines so definitely history and
philosophy of science research so being
able to work in the archives of
different institutions looking through
reading scientist papers their notebooks
their research what were they thinking
as they're excavating these fossils as
they're trying to understand them
I also end up using ended up using a lot
of interviews with current scientists
today and also spending time looking at
the fossils themselves so this is my
subject if if these fossils which
Jennifer was kind enough to bring some
replicas up for our discussion today so
this guy the old man of la Chapelle is a
Neanderthal I felt like if I wanted to
be able to write his story to write his
biography I needed to be able to bring
together all of these kinds of different
sources um so to that end I'd like to
share a couple of stories with you to
kick things off about one of my favorite
fossils and it turns out it's one of
Jennifer's favorite fossils as well the
Tong child from South Africa so this is
a copy this is a cast of what the fossil
looks like it is this is life-sized so
it is definitely a juvenile fossil when
the Tong baby as it's sometimes called
died it was it's estimated that it was
three years old
and the fossil was found in several
parts so we have the first part is this
little facial part so you can see the
back of it you can see his little teeth
you can see it's very tiny you have two
little tiny mandible you don't want to
keep this this is important to keep in
mind for the story that I'm going to
tell you the little tiny mandible here
and
and the third part of the fossil that
made it so interesting is this is
actually a fossilized brain from the
tonk child this fossil was found in 1923
excuse me in 1924 and at that point it
was a fossil that completely changed how
scientists thought about human origins
and human evolution so with that in mind
you've got sort of the tonk child up
here to set the mood I'd like to I'd
like to share a couple of quick stories
here about the tonk child the first time
I ever met a celebrity mmm was on a June
winter morning in Johannesburg I was an
undergraduate a student at a
paleoanthropology field school in
northern in South Africa as part of the
museum or as part of the summers human
paleontology curriculum we attended a
lecture at the university of the fifth
otters rond given by the school's
eminent scientist professor Phillip
Tobias for his talk professor Tobias had
pulled out several well-known fossil
specimens from the university's fossil
vault setting them flat on wooden trays
a topped red velvet showing them off
like rare gems awaiting our appraisal as
we filed into the room to take our seats
as students we had all seen casts so
casts like these of these fossils before
but here we were going to get to see the
real thing professor Tobias was a thin
petite man with a carefully combed set
of with carefully combed white hair and
a meticulously knotted tie at a modest
five foot four I felt as if I towered
over him he arrived for the lecture in
his starched white laboratory coat
clutching a small box small wooden box
that he put it one end of the laboratory
bench he began his lecture by describing
several of South Africa's well known
fossil hominins or human ancestors
picking up one of the hominin specimens
in front of him turning it over in his
hands pointing out an anatomical
characteristic sort of like what we just
did here pointing out a non-atomic eric
turistic of the bone and then carefully
putting the fossil back on his tray the
men exude 'add gravitas and scientific
solemnity the fossils we were looking at
represented decades of research and
epitomized the crucial role that South
Africa plays in understanding human
evolution
as the stories about the different
fossils flowed seamlessly together it
was obvious that professor Tobias had
given this lecture many times before but
we had never heard it and we were
entranced but the [ __ ] but the specimen
that everyone was particularly keen to
see was the tongue child
mmm a fossil whose history has loomed
rather larger than life in the field of
paleoanthropology
professor tobias eventually worked his
way down to the old wooden box at the
end of the table and with a twinkle in
his eye he pulled it a little bit closer
drying out the anticipation he finally
opened the box with theatrical Flair
reverently he pulled out the tiny
cranium and the little tiny mandible the
pieces were small grassle and easily fit
into Tobias his weathered hands he told
us that the wooden box was the same one
that Raymond art himself had used to
store the fossil at the University of
the Vitt mutters Ron for decades and
after recounting the story of how dart
who'd been Tobias his own academic
advisor found the fossil in a box of
breccia from the Buxton line works mine
tobias put the fossil pieces together so
that the lower jaw rested under the
tongue child's tiny face the fossils
stared out at us sort of like sort of
like this
sizing up art group professor tobias
moved a little mandible up and down
cooking the fossils tiny teeth together
and launched into a well-rehearsed
comedy active source that had the tonk
child telling a few jokes
commenting on the weather offering some
insights about the early days of
paleoanthropology with his good pal
Raymond art this ventriloquist unde
shocked silence the veneration that had
surrounded the fossil only moments
before when Tobias described as
historical significance now seemed oddly
out of place to us earnest
undergraduates it was like vaudeville
how could someone is respected as
professor Tobias show off something as
famous as the tonk fossil this way this
wasn't the way we were supposed to
experience it this fossil should be in a
vault a museum display behind glass
anywhere but auditioning is a straight
guy for Laurel and Hardy Act
all right so that was my experience
meeting the tonk child
and I'd like to I'd like to jump back to
talk a little bit about Raymond dart and
to share one of my favorite stories from
the book about the discovery of the
fossil so that was that was me sort of
discovering the fossil and seeing the
real thing as an undergraduate and I'd
like to I'd like to share with you this
the story because it's hilarious and and
it's one as I said it's definitely one
of my favorites so in January of 1924
Raymond dart was a young Australian
anatomist beginning his career at the
University of the Witwatersrand in
Johannesburg charged by the university
to create a medical and Anatomy
department dart had spent two years
prior studying neuroanatomy in London
under the mentorship of British
neuroanatomists er Grafton Elliot Smith
at the end of his studies in London made
possible by scholarship the prominent
anatomist Sir Arthur Keith persuaded
dart to apply for a newly vacant
position in Johannesburg
although dart was rather horrified at
the prospect of heading to South Africa
away from the scientific community of
London he successfully applied for the
position with every intention of
returning to London at some point in the
future when dirt arrived at the
University of the FIB letters Ryan T
began to establish academic curricula as
well as the school's medical program one
of his more popular classes had students
out collecting fossils and comparing the
specimens they found with the bones of
other extant species as a means of
identifying their discoveries dart
encouraged his students to collect
fossil curiosities for the class and
soon fossil animals trickled into the
laboratories in the classrooms
laboratory in early 1924 darts only
female student Josephine Salmons saw a
particularly curious fossil being used
as a paperweight on the directors desk
at the Buxton line marks my quarry where
a friend of hers work she could tell
that the fossil was some sort of primate
and guessed that there was a deeper
evolutionary significance to the fossil
than that of a mere curio so she asked
the quarry director whether her mentor
professor Raymond dart could take a look
at it dartz assessment of the fossil
that it was was indeed that it was a
very old circa petticoat or extinct
species of baboon finding a fossil
priming was exceedingly tremendous for
dart and his students because it meant
that other primates could be part of the
South African fossil record
as an anatomist interested in the
structure and evolution of the human
brain dart was keen to collect specimens
that could shed light on early evolution
of primate brains dirt as salmon's to
convey his very active interest in any
fossils discovered at the light Mark's
mine and even proposed offering a small
financial reward to any worker who
procured interesting specimens the
director of Northern Line company mr. a
e spheres himself an amateur enthusiast
and collector of fossil curios readily
agreed to stockpile the fossils although
he declined
dartz offer for monetary compensation on
behalf of his workers which I just found
crazy
thus the director the Buxton line works
mr. e G is odd set about collecting the
more interesting fossils from the mines
from the mines of workman which thanks
to the region's rich limestone geology
were plentiful fossils from the line
works quarry were collected and shipped
back to dart to dart back in
Johannesburg that fall in October of
1924 dart received a crate of fossils
from the mine the day he and his wife
were to host a wedding with dart is the
best man upon the arrival of the crate
darts wife Dora was less than impressed
in his autobiography dart rather
paternalistically describes Dora's
reaction I suppose those are the fossils
you've been expecting why on earth did
they have to arrive today of all days
now Raymond the guests are going to be
arriving shortly and you can't to go
delving into all of that rubble until
the wedding's over and everyone is left
I know how important the fossils are to
you but please leave them until tomorrow
concerns about guests aside dirt
immediately starts rummaging through the
creative fossils and full formal
Edwardians attire he comes across a
small fossilized primate brain that
stopped him cold so this is this is a
copy of what dart is finding in that
crate in the full like formal Edouard
Ian get up the stalked him cold he was
so enthralled with the discovery that
the wedding party had to more or less
drag him down to the ceremony where a
rather put out groom expectantly waited
for dart to perform his duties as best
man dart recalled these pleasant
daydreams were interrupted by the
bridegroom himself tugging at my sleeve
my god ray he said struggling to keep
the nervous urgency out of his voice you
to finish dressing immediately or I'll
have to find another best man the bridal
car is going to be here any minute
reluctantly I replaced the rocks and the
boxes but I carried the endo cast and
the stone from which it had come along
with me and locked them away in my
wardrobe in order to remove the fossils
from the tough Bret's eiated limestone
dirt pilfered several pairs of his
wife's knitting needles and sharpened
them to form pics necessary to get the
rock away from the from the fossil for
the next three months dirt used every
spare moment to patiently chip away the
matrix from the skull then two days
before Christmas the face of a child
emerged from the rock dart wrote I doubt
if there was any parent prouder of his
offspring than I was of my tongs maybe
that Christmas of 1924 it was
immediately christened the Tong child
Raymond and Dora darts fossil Sion so I
wanted to I wanted to share these couple
of stories about this fossil this Tong
child fossil because I feel like these
are these are ways that fossils can
really come to life that they're not
just these static objects in museums
that we sort of walk by but they're
they're things that have stories and
personalities and to that end a certain
celebrity that that's around them so I
wanted to put up a couple of pictures
yep
sorry I should have advanced to that
earlier so this over here over to the
left we do have professor Phillip Tobias
doing his demonstration with the Tong
child it's not animated but you can sort
of use your imagination to picture the
little jaw and the the skull going
together there and on the right is just
a picture of the Tong Child fossil
itself here we have a set of images that
I found in my archival work from the
University of Witwatersrand in
Johannesburg so the scientist in these
pictures is Raymond dart and you can
sort of see him in full scientific getup
he has his own starched white laboratory
coat he's got a microscope the fourth
the fourth picture in the series that is
in the book smoking a pipe so it really
is sort of this character of a scientist
and he's and dart is very much trying to
sort of present himself
as this as this very eminent scientist
and since he is an eminent scientist his
fossil is important and so it's sort of
creating this whole visual picture that
I thought was really interesting this is
a photo of the box so when I was talking
about
Tobias sort of opening up the box and
all of that kind of good stuff that is
the box itself it actually has its own
catalog and museum number right next to
the fossil it's the only piece of sort
of cultural artifact or cultural
ephemera that is part of the fossil
hominid vault at the University of bit
butters rat and you can see the three
parts that are sort of nestled in there
in their little foam of the Taung child
fossil but the tom child is one of seven
that that i wrote about and that i
researched and so i wanted to just
quickly throw out the other six so you
could see okay what other fossils kind
of followed this this pattern of
research and celebrity on the upper yes
it does alright so here on the upper
left we have a couple of scrappy pieces
this is actually the Piltdown fossil it
was a couple of pieces of crania so
skull a couple of teeth a little bit of
mandible fragment and for 40 years it
was considered the most important fossil
in paleoanthropology in 1953 it's
discovered that it's actually a hoax
it's not a fossil it's not really it's
not really a real thing
and it is now the longest perpetrated
hoax in the entire history of science
I'm not sure quite whether
paleoanthropology is gonna take a bow
about that or not but it is the longest
perpetrated hoax over here we have a
fossil
it's Peking man from Zoo Kotian and
China it was discovered in the 1930s it
was discovered in the late 1920s
excavated and cast and copied in the
1930s and then when Beijing or Peking as
it was then was invaded during World War
Two the fossils were shipped out for
fear of being destroyed and when the
fossils were shipped out they
disappeared they've never been seen
again
so it's sort of this Maltese Falcon
kind of film noir take on on missing
fossils and what that means in the
history of science over here we have the
old man of la Chapelle so in the end yes
we have which is a copy of it up here so
definitely afterwards feel free to kind
of peruse if you want to see what and
the Ender thought skull looks like we do
have a copy up here and I was interested
in researching about the old man of La
Chapelle because because Neanderthals
carries so much in some ways character
they carry so much cultural resonance
Jennifer and I were talking earlier and
we sort of were we were sort of
concerning the question with if I call
you a Neanderthal it has such a negative
connotation but it shouldn't I mean
these are scientifically really
sophisticated this is a really
sophisticated species so how does that
change and so that was part of what I
wanted to research about the old man of
La Chapelle we have Lucy I see a couple
of people nodding so it's great yet we
have Lucy over here the tongue child
that we talked about and then sediba
back there on the cover of science
magazine so debo was discovered in 2008
in South Africa by a professor Lee
Berger actually Lee Byrd her son tripped
over the fossil but which is another
great origin story for a fossil and
sediba has actually been on the cover of
science magazine three times which is a
feat that is unrepeated in any
discipline any scientific discipline no
one and no scientist has had their
research on the cover of science more
than more than Lee Berger has with the
fossil sediba and so I was interested in
exploring this fossil how did how does
it this is a fossil that sort of came of
age and social media I mean it has its
own Twitter handle it has its you know
its own sort of publicity marketing and
sort of well what does what does that
mean for a fossil to be famous does that
take I'm just just to throw out there
how absolutely permeating oh and I
forgot the 7th one there have flow or
Homo floresiensis also known as The
Hobbit
popularly okay I see lots of folks
nodding that's awesome so yeah and the
kinds of kinds of people and lo and
behold there is a short sort of
three-foot-tall hobbit ii looking fossil
that comes out of Indonesia and Flores
and so I found that this was this really
interesting mix of science meeting
popular culture almost almost
simultaneously we also have 2001 the
Space Odyssey you can get a t-shirt with
Lucy printed on it that says I Love Lucy
I am not ashamed to admit that I have
this t-shirt i wear this t-shirt we have
as I said 2001 we have requests for fire
for any of the cult classic oh there are
excellent ok we definitely have some
some Neanderthal enthusiasts that's
fantastic that was I had to convince my
husband to watch quest for fire with me
and I think that I think he was done
with a movie when we were when we were
done with that holy cow um so yeah so
there are lots of lots of different ways
that that these fossils pop up in pop
culture the final one here is Hawaii
five-o the 1970s Hawaii five-o wide ties
stilted dialogue the whole the whole
nine yards with that they actually run
an episode that's looking for the
missing fossils from Zuko Deanna and
China so again I wanted to sort of show
this as I mean it's sort of humorous
it's kind of funny but to also show that
scientific discoveries and sort of what
what we take away from science really
permeates in a lot of ways popular
culture so at this point maybe we should
just start talking about celebrity
science all this kind of cool stuff and
definitely we have time saved so so keep
keep your questions and I hope we I hope
you guys have lots of questions about
famous fossils and all that kind of good
stuff
I wanted to start out by talking a
little bit about science and the idea
that things are always objective in
science and I think one of the things
that your book really highlights is the
fact that science is actually very
subjective in a very human endeavor and
so I was wondering if you could talk a
little bit about how the identity of
some of these fossils is driven by the
subjectivity of the discoverers and the
folks that are promoting these fossils
right I think that that's one of the
things as you point out that really that
really I feel like permeates the book is
sort of looking at the social process of
science that science you knows whether
were whether we're sort of trying to
learn how old the fossil is what it ate
what kind of environment it lived in all
of these things are very much done in
sort of the social context these are
scientists these are graduate students
these are people going about the
business of doing that and their
decisions end up having effects on how
how fossils are understood how they're
received and as you say sort of shape
the the social context for them one of
the things that was the most interesting
for me to find out about the sort of
relationship between science and
celebrity was when I was researching the
fossil Lucy which is which is one of the
most well known fossils and I found out
that actually three weeks after Lucy was
discovered less than three weeks after
Lucy was discovered the discovere dr.
Donald Johanson held the first press
conference to sort of introduce this
amazing fossil and I had no idea that
that soon after the fossil was
discovered that that there was this sort
of wanting to appeal to the wanting to
appeal to sort of public audiences that
hey this is a fossil that's going to be
great and at that point Lucy actually
gets her name I mean she's introduced to
the to the general public and to fossil
enthusiasts at this at this press
conference as Lucy so before she even
gets her scientific name before there's
any kind of scientific study that's done
about her she's Lucy and I was really
fascinated that that could that that
could sort of carry her for 40 years now
the people could know Lucy even if maybe
you didn't know what what her scientific
name was or what she ate or what you
know how long ago she lived people could
still feel like they knew that and I
but that was a really powerful thing to
be able to to explore wanted to return
to the point that you made a few minutes
ago
I always tell my students when they take
my human evolution class if I call you a
Neanderthal I am NOT insulting you in
our circles that is a compliment for
most people they would find that serve
surprising and some wondering if you
could talk a little bit about why it
would be a compliment for me to call you
a Neanderthal I'm really excited about
that this has made my day here right so
when the inner thoughts were first
discovered in 1856 they were discovered
in the Neander Valley in Germany which
is where the name comes from and
scientists didn't really know what to
make of it I mean it sort of looked like
this funky-looking cumin it looked like
a human that wasn't quite right that
it's sort of well you know it's kind of
it's thick it's the skulls kind of
squished down it's got these brows right
it's got these kind of these giant brows
it really just nobody knew exactly what
to really think of it what to make of it
and so all of the interpretations that
came out from the scientific community
based on that were that this was that
this was some sort of primitive human
that it was species that would be
incapable of complex thought it was hey
this is the species that couldn't even
make it out of the Pleistocene right
this is the species that went extinct so
you know how smart could the species
really be and and so for for a long time
that's that that sort of idea really
dominated how people thought about
Neanderthals and then sort of in the
last several decades as more and more
research about Neanderthals has come out
archaeologists have really revised their
take on the inner Thals but wait a
minute the under those bury their dead
they have sophisticated hunting
strategies they have jewelry they have
complex thought they have speech they
have I mean all of these characteristics
that for decades scientists thought
those are things that only belong to
Homo sapiens suddenly we're finding them
here in the and earth also as well and
so there's this huge shift to sort of
humanize Neanderthals or Neanderthal
eyes humans that wait a minute we're not
we're not quite so separate as maybe we
thought we were and so I think that
that rewriting of that public image that
you know it's not just quest for fire
anymore that we're trying to sort of
understand Neanderthals in a more human
or more Neanderthal way and to sort of
take them on their own terms I think has
really contributed to understanding the
under Thals differently now I also
wanted to come back to our favorite our
favorite little part as well here the
tongue child and when Raymond dart
announced him in 1924 there was a lot of
resistance to accepting this as an early
human and I wanted to know what role did
Piltdown man play what role did race and
racism play in the acceptance of this in
the scientific community yeah let me
just jump back a slide here so that
we've got we've got a couple of pictures
to go with that so when the tongue child
was found in 1924 the middle one there
the the fossil that really that really
had captivated the scientific community
the one that everybody cared about was
the Piltdown fossil so those scrappy
scrappy parts up there that was the
fossil that the scientific community out
of London and I want to emphasize that
it was out of London and the European
scientific circles really cared about
was Piltdown that Piltdown fossil the
reason that people cared about it so
much is when they reconstructed it sort
of put it together to make it look like
to make it look like a complete skull
scientists saw that this was a that this
was a fossil that had a big brain so it
must have had complex culture they
thought it was very old so this is sort
of the oldest modern human in Europe of
course it's going to be in Britain you
know where else you know the the legacy
of human civilization all of that kind
of good stuff and so in some ways
Piltdown was exactly the kind of fossil
scientists expected to see and it was
exactly the kind of fossil that they
found and so because it was historic
sort of in looking back at it we see it
now as like this fantastic example of
confirmation bias that it's exactly what
you expected to find so it's really hard
to challenge something when it so
perfectly fits the scientific paradigm
and so when dirt found the tongue child
it was it
even for even accounting for you know at
being a juvenile it had this very small
brain and it could walk on two legs and
it was from South Africa and so it
didn't really have any of the scientific
characteristics that that people thought
ought to ought to be the earliest kind
of human ancestor and so dart in some
ways was fighting an uphill battle and
it really wasn't until additional
fossils were found in South Africa to
really bolster the idea no this isn't
this isn't just some funky you know
monkey that that we found in South
Africa this is a hominid this is a human
ancestor this is this is a fossil that
has a lot of other other or this is a
species that has a lot of fossils that
that really took hold and it was also it
really wasn't until 1953 when Piltdown
was debunked to finally hilltowns out
suddenly the scientific community is
more open to these other fossils that
had been floating around for decades
prior to that so I think it's a
combination of stuff but yeah definitely
Piltdown has sort of become the the
rallying cry the sort of hey let's let's
be really sure and really careful that
we're not sort of seeing what we want to
see in the data
you mentioned the popular depictions of
early humans and of course one that is
most familiar to a lot of us of a
certain age is 2001 and the opening
scene one of the you know famous scenes
of the early humans around this this
mysterious obelisk is actually a
depiction of hypothesis known as the
killer ape hypothesis that was made
forward in the 20th century how does
this compare with the view that hominids
were actually at the mercy of their
environment and that you know they they
were kind of living in this this harsh
place and trying to survive yes great
bye yeah and so certainly when dart
discovered the tongue child and the
australopithecines which actually are
the basis for 2001 there's some great
correspondence between dart and Kubrick
of all people Kubrick's actually asking
dart about his you know his research and
his research about you know sort of this
early bloody you no idea of humanity
this origin for Humanity so so dart has
the sense that humanity's origin is very
violent very troubled very much this
sort of killer ape idea and for for a
while it definitely was was sort of day
report in anthropological circles to
think about history that way
however dart really held on to this
hypothesis much longer than most other
anthropologists by the night and so the
hypothesis was really was really
prevalent in the late 1940s through the
1950s and by the 1960s anthropologists
are sort of saying you know this is a
small this is a really small creature
that's living in a really harsh
environment and you know there are
leopards and there are Eagles and there
are lots of ant this is not an easy way
to be a top this is not a top predator
and so at that point the hunter sort of
becomes the hunted at that point
although dart definitely hangs on to
this this idea for a lot longer than
most anthropologists but again the Tong
child is sort of one of the the fossils
that really forces this question into
into the public's mind absolutely okay
we have a few minutes left and we would
like to open it up to the audience we'd
like to ask if you could please keep
your questions short so we can get as
many of them in and I will try to repeat
the questions that everybody can hear it
and we'll turn over to
have they ever discovered the reason for
the tonk child's death and just I'm
being reminded from back here yes and
from up there as well and that there is
a microphone for projection but yes
we've got your question the reason for
the tonk child's death which is actually
a really awesome question it's really
fun so for a long time scientists
thought that it had actually been eaten
by a leopard so in the in the in the
fossil there are actually little
puncture marks up or in the orbits of
the eye and so scientists thought that
leopards had acted you could actually
match it to like tooth tooth marks and
then about 5 or 7 years ago there was
another study that was done and it
actually matches Eagle Talon marks much
better so the current the current sort
of best guess for how the tongue child
met his demise is that he was carried
off by an eagle that it's it's a small
little hominid and life is rough and the
place to sit play a Pleistocene so yeah
Eagles yeah you said he the tongue child
was the Australian fileted thickest
gasket how old is that I mean how many
with sort of what's the what's the damn
range for the Australopithecus and so
the tongue child is dated to about three
and a half million years ago this
species has sort of a wide range and I
think the lower range is right around
2.8 million and it goes right up to
about 4 million I think is sort of the
best the best estimates and again sort
of the the very narrow windows are
always changing but if you think three
to three-and-a-half million years old
that's a pretty good bet so yeah so life
is rot three and a half million years
ago and the Neanderthals did they come
out of Africa so the animals are a
really interesting speed fossil species
because they're one of the only ones
that are specific to Europe Eurasia and
into the eastern part of Asia sort of as
far east as Uzbekistan and Neanderthals
are about 300,000 years olds who and -
about they went extinct 27 to 30
thousand years ago
apparently recently but geographically
we don't find Neanderthals in Africa the
farthest south would be the Middle East
but what was that their origin yep okay
Sarah they're specific to their specific
to Europe and to Eurasia oh it's
interesting I thought I thought so I
think I see your question a little bit
better and so we do have sort of species
that are ancestral to both modern humans
and to Neanderthals sort of species like
the tonk child or other species and we
do see those coming out of Africa but we
don't see but it but it takes several
million years it takes a lot of
environmental changes a lot of sort of
genetic drift all of that kind of good
stuff but specifically the species is is
in Europe Eurasia eastern parts are
western parts of Asia but earlier
ancestors we would see come out of
Africa but that's a really good question
it's a really complicated way to answer
it - yeah can you describe your
experience in Iran sure uh sure so I was
actually there as a member of the
American Alpine Club rock climbing team
I spent some time there on an exchange
program and as part of that I was
excited to have the opportunity to to
visit different archaeological sites
different paleo sites places that would
be hard to visit without that kind of
visa that kind of access and so parts of
that have definitely contributed to
research that I've done in sort of
nationalism and national symbols of
fossils particularly for Neanderthals
and some of the other fossils that have
come out of Iran but there isn't
anything sadly that pops up in seven
skeletons for for that research but it's
definitely informed other projects that
I've done
damn question from the back
I was wondering how often do you usually
find non bone like human structures like
Blaine's or eyes'll tongues fossilized
and how does that change how you look at
the bones that are found with it that's
a really awesome question actually and
it's such a broad question that I'm
trying I'm trying to think how to how to
give you a good answer so the short
answer is most of the soft tissue
doesn't fossilize that it's just it's
not conducive it it withers it rots it
does all of these sorts of soft tissue
kinds of things and that when a bone
becomes a fossil it's actually the
mineral content is actually being
replaced right exactly
and so what is so unique about the Tong
child is that there is this fossilized
brain case and it's actually the only
one of its kind and so in some ways
that's part I think of Raymond darts
uphill battle also that you have this
fossil that nobody knows even how to
make any sense of in any stretch of the
imagination but other than that I'm
trying to think of other examples of
soft tissue not soft tissue the fact
that the bones preserve is actually a
miracle in itself I mean really the fact
that we have as many fossils as we do is
a result of the perfect circumstances
there may be happen to be a volcanic
eruption and then there was rain and
then there was another eruption that put
another layer of ash down and it
preserved it you really have to have
those levels of circumstances and I
think that you know we had a recent fine
maybe I think 2002 where they found
what's called the hyoid bone in the
throat of an Australopithecus een
related to Lucy and it's this little
tiny thin bone that tells us something
about speech and the way that sounds
were made and that in itself was a
miracle so I mean you just look at what
are the odds and so it's really amazing
to see that and I another question that
I get a lot of is sort of how many so if
it's so rare how many Neanderthals do we
have sort of in the fossil record and
it's just over 400
so in some ways that's an awful lot and
not very many at the same time but yeah
it really is this amazing set of right
circumstances for fossils to be able to
preserve other question yet I've been
reading something read something
recently and I can't even remember if it
was in science or something else that
there is apparently some DNA evidence
that there's actually some cross species
things going on between the and earth
halls and in humans yeah absolutely
and how that happened and indeed that
there might even be I don't know if I
got this correct or not but some relic
or fossil evidence that the and earth
all's might have been very responsible
for their survival of the folk who
migrated up from Africa into Central
Europe can you talk about that a little
bit sure and again that's a really
awesome question and such a such a great
complex question at the same time so
I'll preface this also by saying that I
am NOT a geneticist and so for sort of
if you really want to drill down and to
get some of the specifics for Jetix I
would suggest checking out the blog of
John Hawkes who's a who's a
paleoanthropologist and he's got some
great posts sort of on this very
specific question that you're asking but
sort of but to sort of get back to your
question yes there is definitely genetic
and morphological evidence for humans
and Neanderthals crossbreeding that
there's a lot of overlap all of that
kind of good stuff but sort of as to how
exactly those genetic traits trace into
different populations whether it's other
species whether it's other
well we've got that now if everyone
saved okay I'm sorry I couldn't quite
bring myself to talk over this but it
gave you another moment to gather my
thoughts so it was actually this really
awesome opportunity um but to answer
your question this is sort of like one
of the hot topics right now in
paleoanthropology research and so a lot
of what's being published is sort of the
first take on what what these kind of
genetic populations would look like
where they would go and what they would
mean for sort of the story of human
evolution I think if you were to ask
that question in a year or in five years
that I'd have a lot more interesting
stuff to be able to tell you but the
whole field of paleo genetics is less
than five years old and so a lot of this
just is really new
KS yes and I'm just to wrap up we were
mentioning that we were discussing
whether or not we were going to get our
DNA test because when you really want to
know how much mannitol we have it so
yeah exactly
yes back there that's great so I again I
just wanted to say thank you all so much
for coming to talk fossils so thank you
very much thank you to Lydia thank you
to you for being here and we encourage
you to stop by the Barnes & Noble
signing to 10th just outside Lydia will
be heading over there momentarily with
her 3d prints of the Taung child so and
who doesn't want to check out some casts
we definitely check them out yeah
here's a look at some of the upcoming
book fairs and festivals happening
around the country on April 22nd and
23rd book TV will be live from the Los
Angeles Times Festival of Books held on
the campus of the University of Southern
California and on May 20th will be live
from the Gaithersburg Book Festival in
Maryland just north of Washington DC and
from May 31st June 2nd look for us at
the publish industries annual trade show
Book Expo America in New York City where
we'll sit down with authors and
publishers to discuss their forthcoming
books for more information about the
book fairs and festivals book TV will be
covering and to watch previous festival
coverage click the book fairs tab on our
website book tv.org but the other sort
of contribution that I think the book or
I hope the book has is a discussion of
the domestic cadaver trade and this is a
trafficking of dead bodies I traced
medical school records anatomy
professors that were involved in this
traffic and they wrote letters back and
forth to one another looking for the
dead bodies of enslaved people or
exhuming them from graves one of one of
the pivotal quotes that I have is a
quote from one medical doctor to the
other that's saying you know tell me how
much it costs for a dead stiff inward
you know one that you can that that you
can't excuse me do tell me what the cost
is of a dead fine stiff in he continued
one that will cut up fat and doesn't
smell strong enough to be new nosed a
mile off and so I traced this traffic
and then there's trade in these bodies
and I look at the ways in which even
after death enslaved people were
commodified so just two final closing
short like one sentence quotes that kind
of help me push through this book and
that is a quote from Elizabeth Keckley
who some of you may know was the
enslaved seamstress to Martha Jefferson
and she says here when she talks about
what death was like at the
at least we shall be permitted to lay
our burdens down that a new world a
world of brightness may open to us the
light that is denied us here should grow
into a flood of effluence beyond the
dark mysterious shadows of death I
thought that was just a powerful way to
think about how enslaved people looked
at their after lives and then finally
I've shared this when I was here a few
weeks ago a slave named Mingo wrote a
poem on the beam of a jail cell wall to
his wife after they had been separated
and he says to her dear wife they cannot
sell the Rose of love but in my bosom
glows remember as your tears may start
they cannot sell by I mortal part thank
you you can watch this and other
programs online at book tv.org we're at
the rotunda at thomas jefferson's
university of virginia
up next we take you to their Special
Collections library to learn more about
the Jefferson Papers
Jefferson is the founder of UVA he
worked for many many years to develop
the system of education in Virginia
UVA was his he said it was his last
great project which he did after he left
the White House he designed the
buildings he designed the curriculum he
served as the first rector or chair of
the Board of Visitors he was intimately
involved as you will see and a lot of
the details about building the buildings
so pretty much everything you can think
of his vision was it's a term that gets
thrown around a lot today called an
Academical village and if you look at
his plans for the university at the time
a lot of universities basically
consisted of one very big building where
classes were held and there were
dormitory rooms and things like that and
Jefferson's idea was to essentially make
a village out of it with the students
living near the professors and classes
being given in the professor's homes and
you know so there was all this constant
interaction of student and faculty plus
it's in Charlottesville in the 1820s
which is a very small town a village
really and so if you think about these
amazing buildings that went up in the
early 1820s sitting out essentially in
the middle of nowhere in Virginia you
know it was part of his ideal of you
know the United States is an agrarian
society and the elite becoming leaders
of the country and all that sort of
thing well the University Archives are
the official historical records of the
University and they go back to actually
long before the university was chartered
by the state that was in 1819 and
records go back to 1814 to the two
institutions that preceded UVA the
archives as I said are about four
million items it's the records of the
board of
visitors it's the records of the
president the deans the Provost's the
library every facet of the university
its paper its sound recording its video
recording its digital materials its
email its websites you know anything
that's a historic record of the
University we try to capture well these
are some of the very early records some
that go back to 1817 this is a letter
that Jefferson wrote in 1817 to William
Thornton who was the man he assigned to
work on the United States Capitol
building when he was president so they
were very good friends and Jefferson
wrote to Thornton about his ideas for
the university and you'll see in the
middle he included a little sketch of
what he was thinking a sort of
open-ended rectangle with pavilions
interspersed with dormitory rooms very
regularly and then an open area that he
says is grass and trees no no more
detail than that and so that's one of
his very first conceptions for the
university it's a basic part of the idea
but it changed dramatically between the
time he drew that sketch and the
university was actually completed it was
about nine years after this sketch this
was 1817 and the university was
essentially complete in 1826 each of the
ten pavilions were inhabited by a
professor and they talked they actually
taught their classes there in the
pavilion and so they lived among the
students and the students lived adjacent
to the faculty and that was one of
Jefferson's idea that the proximity
would result in you know all kinds of
educational and intellectual exchange so
this is Pavilion seven it's the first
building that was constructed at the
University it's now the colonnade Club
which is a Faculty Club this was
actually constructed again before the
university was chartered in 1819
and this is one of Jefferson's
architectural drawings he did it drawing
like this with an elevation and floor
plans for each of the ten pavilions you
can see he didn't quite get his scale
right and had to glue on a small piece
of paper to complete the chimney stack I
kind of like that it makes him a little
more human I think that he could
actually make a mistake like that and so
this is an example the ground floor of
the pavilion here is two large rooms the
upstairs and the cellar this is the
cellar this is the upstairs the upstairs
would be the living room for the family
and the lower floor of the cellar was
where the cooking happened and where
some of the slaves who worked for the
professors would have lived obviously
you can see it's it's neoclassical and
he was very much interested in classical
architecture one of his big source books
was the four books of architecture by
Andrea Palladio in an edition in English
that came out I believe in 1721 and he
used those to draw inspiration
especially for the pavilions for the the
various pavilions each one is different
he wanted the university to be an
open-air classroom even in its building
so you can walk around and see examples
of classical architecture and the
different orders of architecture and
different styles and features and that
was very much a part of what he wanted
to have happen
well so the university got off the
ground officially in 1819 when the
General Assembly gave the university a
charter and gave the university funding
to continue building buildings as very
critical as it always is and this is a
ledger that was maintained by the
Proctor who was essentially the chief
operating officer of the university it's
called a day book and in 18th century
19th century accounting essentially this
is where you wrote down incoming and
outgoing funds every day and you would
eventually transfer them officially to a
ledger you know under the various funds
you'd establish the balances you'd see
all of that sort of thing the great
thing about this is the Proctor actually
made notes to himself about what some of
these expenses were for and so it goes
from you know things like a barrel of
nails to you know five hundred pounds of
flour to X number of board feet of
lumber to you know hauling bricks and
hauling earth and most importantly for
UVA it shows you the source of the labor
that was used to actually build the
buildings and here on this page the
Proctor Arthur Bracken bro has recorded
payments that were made to individuals
for the hire of their slaves and the
slaves are actually named you can see
here is a payment for his Tom that's the
name of a slave and then Barrett and
George so we know who the individuals
were and what the name of the slave was
who was hired to work here at UVA and
this goes on and on and on throughout
the years of construction it's been
identified that probably overall they're
somewhere in the neighborhood of 50 to
75 uniquely named slaves there sometimes
when we're not sure if the same slave
with the same name is
the same person and of course not every
slave was hired for the duration it was
it was common that a slave hire was done
for a year and that on the new year a
new contract would be offered to the
owner and it would be renegotiated I
suspect a lot of this was done on a
monthly or a daily or even a weekly
basis with the owners now if you've
finished moving earth for the terraces
you don't need as much labor so you can
send them back to their owner to work on
the other hand if you have someone who's
a skilled carpenter perhaps or skilled
at making bricks you might need them for
much longer of course this is the
rotunda it is probably the most iconic
building of the university I think it's
what everybody thinks about when they
think of UVA it is based on the model of
the Pantheon in Rome and it's a model
that Jefferson adapted from the pole
audio volumes that I mentioned we always
like to point out that in the lower
corner he says it's the library which of
course it was and it was the library
from when it opened in 1826 until 1938
and we're always very proud of that it
served as the library and a classroom
building there was a chemistry lab in
the basement they were classrooms they
were meeting rooms it was the center of
university life it's changed
dramatically in the 20th century as I
said it was the library until 1938 and
then a new main library alderman library
which is adjacent to this building was
built and the rotunda was then used as
an event space and for offices and
essentially from about World War two
until very recently there was not a lot
of assigned activity to the rotunda it
was more of a ceremonial space
and students could actually go here
there for years without ever having to
go into the Rotunda which didn't really
seem like quite the right thing and so
recently the Rotunda is undergone about
about two years worth of repair and
renovation and with an eye specifically
to making it more accessible and more
appealing to students to use to study in
the dome room to study in the other
rooms and have it open later at night
have spaces that more classes can meet
so they're trying really hard and I
think it's a great idea to bring it back
to the center of academic life and not
just have it as a big Monument sitting
at the head of lawn I think there's no
question that Jefferson would be
astonished about UVA today surely from
size alone I mean if you think about the
size of the original buildings versus
what exists now at UVA it's it's immense
the student body is enormous and before
the Civil War
I believe the highest enrollment you VA
had was something like 800 students you
know now we're in the tens of thousands
of students obviously other things that
would astonish him are the fact that
women are being educated at UVA and
African Americans are being educated at
UVA and students from all around the
world are being educated at UVA and yet
there's still a great deal about his
original vision that has survived and I
think that is probably as astonishing as
anything
this is book TV on c-span - television
for series